allez on va parler la campagne
présidentielle on va ouvrir le premier
débat de ce club sur valérie pécresse
puisqu'elle donné hier son premier grand
meeting de campagne c'était au zénith de
paris elle a réuni à 7500 personnes et
l'objectif de ce meeting c'est est de
relancer la dynamique de sa campagne un
sujet de pierre henry holder moments
elles s'est présenté seul devant la
foule militante réunis au zénith de
paris un discours très attendu présenté
comme majeur pour relancer sa campagne
alors valérie pécresse n'hésite pas à
marcher sur les terres de ses
concurrents d'extrême droite il n'y a
pas de souveraineté sans frontières nous
devons les restaurer la frontière c'est
comme la porte de la maison c'est portes
nous choisissons de l'ouvrir ou de la
fermer c'est cela être maître chez soi
et si pour cela il faut bâtir des
barrières loin des murs comme le
souhaitent les états qui sont en
première ligne face au chantage
migratoires je les soutiendrai le
discours s'est durci la candidate heller
à la présidentielle qui n'a pas hésité à
employer le terme de grand remplacement
avant d'aborder aussi frontalement le
dossier du voile pour moi le voile n'est
pas un vêtement comme les autres ce
n'est pas une prescription religieuse
c'est un signe de soumission de la femme
- présidente de la république
aucune femme ne sera soumise je
n'accepterai jamais de soumettre la
république m'a rien n'est pas une femme
voilée mais il fallait aussi fendre
l'armure valérie pécresse à l'instar de
marine le pen il y à peu à éclairer
quelques aspects de sa vie privée est en
droit de savoir qui je suis je suis né
un 14 juillet ce jour de fête nationale
où la france se rassemblent et célèbrent
en même temps la prise de la bastille et
la fête de la fédération
la révolution et la réconciliation
nationale
un 14 juillet aux couleurs de la france
nouvelle souhaité par valérie pécresse
qui pour certains n'a pas su convaincre
lors de ce grand rendez vous arnon
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé à première
vue de ce grand meeting de valérie
pécresse
normalement c'était difficile on voit
que c'est une candidate qui n'est pas à
l'aise dans ce type d'exercice et je
constate que la plupart des commentaires
vont dans ce sens
après bon le parti républicain est un
parti qui s'est encore mobilisés la
différence peut-être du parti socialiste
et de ce point de vue là ils ont réussi
à remplir la salle donc ils peuvent au
moins se satisfaire de cette
mobilisation et j'entends un certain
nombre d'ailleurs de leurs responsables
se satisfaire déjà de cette mobilisation
après on voit bien que il ya une
pression qui s'exerce sur la droite de
valérie pécresse et que finalement le
grand enseignement de ce meeting par
delà les imperfections
oratoire c'est surtout que elle a choisi
une ligne politique cas qui est une
ligne à droite dans laquelle elle
comprend que il lui faut aujourd'hui
récupérer une partie de l'électorat qui
est parti chez l'exe moore voir chez
marine le pen pour pouvoir se qualifier
au second tour de la présidentielle
alors la difficulté après qui se pose
c'est la sincérité de cette expression
que d'aucuns mettent en doute notamment
chez ses concurrents ensuite c'est la
brutalité de ce tournant parce que on a
le sentiment que on est finalement dans
un virage en épingle à cheveux qui
soudain est pris par une
personnalité politique il était plutôt
sur une ligne quand même sans trop
libérale ces dernières années qui avait
quitté il faut s'en souvenir le les
républicains parce qu'elle considérait
que le président de l'époque laurent
wauquiez faisait pencher le curseur
trompe à droite donc tout ça aujourd'hui
laisse en suspens un certain nombre
d'interrogations après je pense qu'ils
font pas non plus fétichisé si vous
voulez le rôle que joue ce genre de
meeting
alors en effet on attendait beaucoup du
côté des républicains de ce meeting pour
relancer une campagne manifestement je
suis pas sûr que ce meeting relance la
campagne il y a un problème parce que
l'interprétation du meeting qui est
faite aujourd'hui par la plupart des
commentateurs et la plupart des acteurs
politiques est plutôt porteuse une
tonalité négative
après on va voir je dire les choses
comme on comment les choses vont évoluer
dans les dents les jours et dans les
semaines qui viennent encore une fois le
là sera donné par les différents
sondages qui seront publiés on va pas on
va parler du discours et peut-être du
virage à droite de valérie pécresse dans
son programme dans quelques instants
mais pierre d'abord votre avis comment
vous vous l'avez ressenti ce meeting est
ce qu'elle a fait une performance
valérie pécresse pensait plutôt
difficile oui certainement pas parler de
performance
quoi dire c'est c'est très difficile
parce que toute la semaine en off
l'état-major des républicains disait la
campagne commence dimanche dimanche ça
va être déterminant c'est parti on y va
bon je vais pas revenir sur la forme
passion pas tirer éternellement sur
l'ambulance c'était catastrophique il ya
toujours ce problème - carla sur le ya
un problème d'incarnation et le discours
qu'importe le discours quand on ne
s'approprie pas les mots ça peut être
que mauvais donc pas revenir sur la
forme il suffit de regarder
ce qui s'est passé hier pour comprendre
c'est sur le fond que
moi j'ai énormément énormément
d'interrogations c'est à dire que
valérie pécresse est en train de se
placer dans un couloir où il ya déjà
deux candidats qui se partagent 20% des
suffrages
valérie pécresse a quitté l air parce
que la ligne wauquiez était trop à
droite elle a fondé libre parce que
c'était une libérale justement parce que
effectivement je pensais qu'elle allait
chasser sur les terres du du centriste
du centre-droit capter ou cooptés par
par emmanuel macron et le fait que ses
adversaires ces dernières semaines ont
eu comme élément de langage macro égale
pécresse elle s'est droitisée s'est fait
de façon tellement un brutal de
maladroite et 3 ni très fine ni très
intelligente que ça donne quelque chose
sur le fond d' extrêmement raté et le
militant républicain
qui suit valérie pécresse justement pour
parce qu'il ne votera pas eric zemmour
parce qu'il votera pas marine le pen et
qui voulait une interminable une
alternative à emmanuel macron là ça va
être quand même très très très compliqué
dont il ya cette espèce hier de deux
points d'interrogation non pas tant sur
la forme voilà le mileu l'exercice était
ratée je pense pas qu'elle soit
extrêmement doué en meeting on l'a vu
hier mais ça voilà mais sur le fond même
ça pose une vraie question ne serait ce
que sur la stratégie adoptée c'est qui a
conseillé sa stratégie est de faire ça
de façon aussi brutale et aussi violente
j'ai bien une petite idée de qui lui a
conseillé sa rachida dati l'a dit aussi
simplement on verra les sondages
peut-être peut-être que je me trompe je
pense que c'est une très très mauvaise
stratégie et justement dans ce discours
sur le fond pour la première fois
valérie pécresse a utilisé un mot
qu'elle détestait il ya quelques mois
c'est le mot de grand remplacement c'est
un concept que clay d'extrême droite et
dans le programme d'eric zemmour on va
écouter valérie pécresse
pour la première fois le sort du monde
pourrait s'écrire sans nous dans dix ans
serons nous encore la septième puissance
du monde serons nous encore une nation
souveraine ou un auxiliaire des états
unis un comptoir de la chine
serons-nous une nation unie ou une
nation éclaté
face à ces questions vitales pas de
fatalité ni aux grandes et classement ni
au grand remplacement
par nos métiers on avait bruno
retailleau tout à l'heure qui disait que
c'était une obsession de journalisme de
s'intéresser à cette utilisation du mot
grand emplacement mais quand même ça a
une signification politique le fait
qu'elle utilise oui alors les mots ont
un sens mais quand on la réécoute
manifestement elles l'utilisent pas
forcément dans le sens qui est le sens
qui lui est donnée par celui qui a
conceptualisé cette formule l'écrivain
renaud camus elle veut éviter elle veut
éviter le gras remplacement si on suit
son raisonnement de la france sur la
scène internationale c'est un peu ce
qu'elles entendent qu'elle entend dire
mais le problème c'est que le mot est
tellement si vous les portes de
controverse afin de faire croire les
mimes de passion que inévitablement dans
sa bouche il ya quelque chose en effet
qui peut surprendre en tout cas ceux qui
ne sont pas les plus je les dirai
identitaire à droite donc oui il ya ya
ya manifestement là dessus une forme de
tournant qui a été opéré mais parce que
si vous voulez moi je pense que le vrai
problème c'est que non seulement elle à
la pression de derry zemmour la pression
de marine le pen mail à l'adresse la
pression à l'intérieur de son propre
camp non il faut quand même pas oublier
que l a gagné face à eric ciotti qui
était sur une ligne très proche de celle
d'eric zemmour et café près de 40% des
suffrages des militants républicains
donc on voit bien que en tout cas l'ailé
droite des républicains qui est
aujourd'hui presque majoritaire d'une
certaine manière suite à ce congrès
exerce en effet un rôle extrêmement
important dans sa campagne alors ensuite
c'est vrai que quand même moi je pense
que mathématiquement mathématiquement à
la mathématique c'est pas la dynamique
électorale certes mais mathématiquement
elle est obligée d'une certaine façon
d'aller trianguler sur cette droite pour
réussir à se qualifier dans la course
très serrée qui est la sienne dans ce
second tour entre marine le pen d'un
côté qui pour l'instant ne démérite pas
dans les sondages et eric zemmour qui
pousse assez fort en tout cas ces
dernières semaines donc pour elle il va
falloir essayer de ramener une partie de
cet électorat pour réussir cette
qualification sinon je ne vois pas où
sont les marges de madame pécresse
d'autant plus que emmanuel macron de son
côté est en train de piocher abondamment
dont l' aile modérée des républicains en
fait elle est quoi est dans une
stratégie qui est celle de françois
mitterrand françois mitterrand disait
toujours il faut rassembler au premier
tour son camp son camp aujourd'hui
clairement et bien il est plutôt le
curseur est plutôt à droite voire très à
droite donc elle essaye de rassembler de
ce côté-là non sans difficulté parce
qu'elle a des concurrents qui sont quand
même assez redoutable marine le pen d'un
côté qui fait preuve d'une certaine
forme de résistance et de résilience
eric zemmour qui lui a réussi à se
transformer dans politique pierre
alignement est ce que justement cette
stratégie qui droite plus radicales de
la part de valérie pécresse ça ne va pas
entraîner d'autres ralliements chez les
républicains verts emmanuel macron comme
on l'a vu la semaine dernière avec eric
woerth l'ancien ministre de nicolas
sarkozy et puis récemment la maire de
calais natacha bouchart si pour moi
c'est un très mauvais calcul parce que
c'est pas justement parce que ce n'est
pas valérie pécresse s'est pas sa ligne
politique
elle n'a cessé de le redire quand y
avait laurent wauquiez fin c'était il ya
quelques années elle a cessé de redire
que c'était un parti rabougri qui se
rétrécit c'est que c'était les mêmes
idées que l'extrême droite que ceux-ci
que cela et elle en est partie donc ce
n'est pas son adn politique ce n'est pas
son adn politique et on ne change pas de
doctrine à deux mois du premier tour
donc moi je pense que ça va pousser
comme vous l'avez dit les plus entre
guillemets modérés libéraux etc qui ne
reconnaissent plus leur candidate verts
emmanuel macron et les républicains qui
hésite et eric zemmour et marine le pen
ils ont l'argument de tout trouvé c'est
préférer l'original à la copie et quand
on entend effectivement des termes comme
grand remplacement alors peut-être que
c'était pour parler effectivement en
revoyant riscle extraits sur la scène
internationale etc enfin bon on va pas
me faire croire que ça a été ce mot a
été choisi au hasard il y avait mille
façons de le dire donc on verra si la
stratégie est payante ou pas je ne crois
pas et à nouveau se placer dans un
couloir où il ya déjà deux personnes qui
se partagent 20% des suffrages c'est
pour le moins un pari audacieux
[Musique]